hello hello and welcome to this video
bring just in Yano five six five and I
will definitely try to play the improve
cup off again improve carp of system
that's how they call that nowadays and
even I am stand to stumble into this
which is not good
sure about the name yeah seems like did
not have this on the right a door which
is usually the case if you know about h5
you don't even castle
now here white is in quite substantial
danger of getting killed quickly we'll
see okay 27 96 it is all very murky that
is definitely the case it's in the
position ma'am if you give that to a
computer um it will give black a really
nice position and it is objectively
probably better for black but it is
extremely complicated I've had my fair
share of games that are lost in those
lines simply because it's just so yeah
out of this world complicated that you
tend to make mistakes okay
this whole operation gives me a really
nice Bishop 187 I wonder if I have
anything better than the obvious Bishop
g6 he will probably play a for next
hmm we go to h7 at least the g6 square
is is open
it's an interesting interesting approach
by my white Bishop g4 as a move I can
play
oh this interesting takes Knight takes
and then h3 next
hmm I'm not sure this is objectively
correct you know let's try it
I didn't even know that he can pose a
question and he just played ev3 yeah but
that is a bit of a I've gained a little
bit with this because now I'm preventing
the f4 takes night eggs operation that
was the idea
let's go to g6 I did not want a knife
come to f4 and then to e6 that was the
thing Knight h5 would be nice to play
that so I'm taking it right I can also
take Knight takes Knight e5 yeah but I
don't like that
that's not let's not do it so I take him
d5 95 is okay
all right h5 I don't know is that a good
news that's probably five very very
complicated and the Bishop of three to
g4 is something that heavily irritates
me not right now because therefore hangs
but that something that could be
extremely problematic I came here I was
thinking 95
and I cannot cancel you I just cannot
castle we've had checked takes Queen
cakes that's a double attack good enough
time
and there might be things connected here
to the H file and the Bishop 187 that's
technically quite dangerous Queen g3 for
example and some scenarios could work
let's check on you six okay this is such
a scenario look F seven I can play queen
g3 I think Queen g3 not sure how much
that really but what it does maybe you
just moves the king okay that's nice
that was odd very odd game the ten do
same to third time zero zero to three
it's kind of funny okay so let's let's
have a look at this yeah as seen quite
often good castles is a mistake due to
age five even white gets under an attack
but as I mentioned it's so murky that
things are things are just difficult to
play so let's see how this turned out
this d5 is interesting and he makes this
bishop especially in connection with the
form this makes this Bishop a much
stronger piece now I took a long time
but Bishop g4 is playable at the end
probably that costs me because of the
the time that was spent yeah here I have
enough attack I think further for the
piece I thought h3 year but this doesn't
seem to be so clear castles a stronger
castles short and nobody plays that one
night f2 castles short is a completely
inhuman move here I mean once you get
pointed to it you see that ok f2 is
under attack
this is a more human way of playing than
loop here so often I therefore the
situation doesn't seem to be clear at
all yeah I was thinking that this is
interesting also Bishop f3 and then
basically go from here I did not
calculate any further I have night f2f
h2 engine gives a slight advantage to
white stuff too I mean in a blitz game
that is not worth much this kind of
revaluation they played f3 I went back
and here must be ok really this is just
too lame to pose a problem after f4 I
think I should be better yeah that it's
not a surprise I don't this is it feels
anti positional but I didn't refute it I
should take it since and then really
play Knight e5 Quincy - and then
castling it's a really difficult move to
make
once you casting short in particular
mmm and it must be if it must be fine
yeah night 96 it's really a good thing I
mean can always just take the engine
gives Bishop of 7 as a good way to
follow up it's very tough to play it's a
very unique position yeah I took on e 2
I took on e tomb but that didn't turn
out to be so well take take and Knight
h5m didn't didn't pay off seems I should
cancel again yeah yeah here I'm in some
trouble I'm in some trouble energy form
doesn't work I cannot cancel any site
and this is an issue you know the
distant work actually doesn't work due
to many things
Luke f5
the truth I don't understand yet fatigue
here then then Queen age three probably
angling for 26 yeah I mean I'm under
attack eh
I have put Queenie seven I didn't even
see that yeah I am I have to say as I
saw Queen g3 and only I did not think
about King edge one the forehand down of
course it came just picking edge one
this is actually quite quite nice him
like here with the double check
it's not like I'm saving myself easily
here but that's what I wanted to do at
King edge one is a simple refutation
yeah very murk here this is a very tough
tough to play position I should just
start to win again this guy you're
higher rated you should lose all the
game but I don't really know what
happened in the in the games that have
performed okay guys thanks for watching